[Musique]
j'avais envie qu'il y avait 200 ciseaux
dans le corps humain de coûts ouais a en
fait ce qui est rigolo c'est que on en a
plus à la naissance qu'à l'âge adulte
parce qu'en fait les ossements pour
grandir il pousse par différents bout tu
as un bout central et deux extrémités
par exemple pour faire un oslo et chaque
chaque petit noyau va grandir grandir
grandir et se rejoindre mais au début
batata deux petits noyaux trois petits
noyaux ceux qui sont reliés par du
cartilage et au fur et à mesure ce
quartier là je vais à s'agrandir est ce
aussi fier c'est pour ça que quand tu
n'es tu as 350 hausse she's un bébé et
puis chez un adulte en a plus que 206
qui est d'ailleurs assez utile parce que
par exemple la boîte crânienne chez un
adulte c'est un seul os et chez un bébé
c'est plein de petits os avec du
quartier d'âge entre les deux et au
moment d'accoucher c'est quand même bien
pratique parce que les os du crâne tu
vois peuvent se superposer légèrement le
monde du passage et du coup ça ça réduit
légèrement
la circonférence de la tête du bébé même
si ça reste compliqué
un peu plus facile et en fait ce qui est
rigolo c'est que ces ossements plus tu
grandis - tu en as donc puisque plus il
se soudent les uns avec les autres et
c'est une manière qu'on a en archéologie
de déterminer l'âge d'un squelette c'est
pour ça que quand tu as terminé sa
croissance je ne peux plus déterminer
l'âge de la mort de quelqu'un à l'année
près avancées possibles hockey est par
exemple est un truc est sympa aussi que
je répétais souvent mes étudiants et
qu'il les ait pas mal rires tu sais
quand on est au collège et au lycée ils
vont dire ouais leschi 100 vaches confus
mature que les garçons et ben en fait
c'est vrai parce que le dernier os à se
souder c'est la clavicule à welch est
une fille ça se soudent de aa2 à a1 en
plus tôt que chez les garçons donc c'est
vrai qu'on est adulte plus rapidement tu
vas
où et quand tu date ans que là tu dois
savoir sa mâle ou une femelle avant qu
effectivement tu as besoin de savoir si
c'est un homme ou une femme pour faire
une estimation la plus précise possible
après il ya différentes tables
différentes écoles tu sais donc en
fonction de la table que tu choisis tu
peux avoir 50 différence sur une
formation ce qui est assez énorme et
surtout cette les anciennes tables ne
prenait en compte que l'os théologie
l'anatomie maintenant on a des scanners
qui nous permettent d'être beaucoup plus
précis sur la différence justement de
croissance entre les filles et les
garçons et aussi en fonction de ta
génétique parce que les populations ont
des rythmes de croissance légèrement
différent
voilà et après donc une fois que tu ne
peux plus daté l'âge de ton squelette
qu'est ce que tu fais pour savoir quel
âge il a ensuite utilisé ce qu'on
appelle des indices de sénescence c'est
à dire des indices comme quoi le
squelette est en train de vieillir donc
à l'arthrite tard le tassement envers ce
genre de choses mais c'est pour le vieux
ça du coup c'est pour les collages
intermédiaire l'âge adulte tu fais
comment
tu
c'est pour ça que dans beaucoup de
documentaires quand tu as des des voix
off qui te disent nous retrouvons le
squelette d'une femme morte à 37 ans tu
dis non je peux pas en fait morte entre
l'âge adulte et le début de la
vieillesse et puis bah la vieillesse
j'adore c'est très différent d'une
personne à l'autre en fonction de ton
activité en fonction de ton état de
santé il ya quelque chose qui pourrait
quand même temps intéressé c'est que en
archéologie on a beaucoup on a voulu
utiliser l'usure dentaire pour essayer
de
l'âge des plus l'ancient des plus vieux
le truc c'est que l'usure dentaire ben
c'est pas uniquement corrélé à ton
alimentation c'est aussi corrélée à
l'activité que tu peux avoir il ya
beaucoup de population qui utilise les
dents comme un outil par exemple les
inuit elle travaille au le cuir avec les
incisives donc l on les incite
complètement raboté et ce n'est pas une
histoire de jeunesse une histoire de
travail manuel quoi est il ya autre
chose aussi qui rentre en compte c'est
la manière dont tu vas créer ta farine
parce que en fonction de la pierre que
tu va choisir pour me l'état farine bien
tu vas voir plus ou moins d'inclusion
minérale à l'intérieur de ta farine et
donc passer ton temps ta vie à manger
ton pain avec des petits bouts de
minéraux de nom ok alors que le soleil
levant sur la seconde pour la santé ou
pas de manger d'el-bouni léo ça j'en
sais rien du tout c'est marrant fin il
ya des pierres qui perdent plus
facilement des boucs d'autres ou pas
ouais je pense genre si tu as du grès le
grès et du sable un dur et donc les
petits grains il doit partir rapidement
mais après les pierres qu'on utilise
pour nous les jeux c'est absolument pas
un procès pour les coûts c'est marrant
ça me regarde je peux en fait tu peux
utiliser n'importe quoi pour créer
mêlant tu es fier lui granik tu peux
utiliser du grès c'est vrai nous on en
trouve beaucoup en granit mais en
fonction de la dureté de la pierre
potentiellement tu vas voir tu prends
ton temps des petits bouts de tamouls
qui va contribuer à tuz et les dents et
donc apte à faire paraître plus âgée aux
yeux des archéologues des semences et du
coup est ce que ça peut intervenir aussi
dans l'alimentation gens c'est
comme si tu prenais un complément
alimentaire
alors ça c'est intéressant il ya des
populations qui effectivement broie les
numéros pour pour en ingérer et il ya
d'ailleurs une histoire en archéologie
en archéologie sud-américaine qui nous
embête beaucoup avec ça c'est que les
petits singes sud américain ils ont
besoin de se complémentent et en numéro
et donc ils cassent les cailloux pour
les léché et les casses donc
intentionnellement donc les cailloux
sont cassés intentionnellement mais pas
pour créer un outil pour aller récupérer
à l'intérieur les oligo éléments sauf
que dans les matériels archéologiques
bas il ya les archéologues qui qui
confondent ces cassures de singe avec
des cassures des premiers hommes
amérindiens donc ça pose un véritable
problème de méthodologie n'est pas top
comment tu fais la différence aulas
alors là là ça n'empêcherait pas la même
pour tous
sinon si en fait en vrai je peux je te
répondre quand tu cassin un caillou
juste pour aller chercher un oligo
éléments la seule chose que tu veux
faire c'est l'ouvrir en découvrirons
donc tu t'en fous de lax exactement
alors que si tu veux un caillou pour
faire quelque chose tu vas forcément au
moins une envie de tranchant ou une
envie de en tout cas une envie de
parties actives qui généralement est un
tranchant mais qui peut être aussi une
petite pointe pour percer ou quelque
chose pour racler est généralement bas
se tranchant il va être opposé à une
partie que tu peux tenir parce que c'est
évidemment tout est tranchant bah tu te
retrouves à te couper les doigts ou à
devoir créer une ans un petit peu
bizarre mais généralement l'intuition du
tailleur de pierre c'est d'avoir donc
une partie qu'on appelle près en civ qui
est confortable pour ta main et de
l'autre côté une partie active hockey
comme sur nos couteaux quoi il n'y a pas
que une âme ans exactement comme sur le
couteau
cool c'est incroyable du coup c'est
marrant j'ai trouvé surtout des meules
en granit parce que non en même temps
c'est complètement logique puisque le
granit c'est une pierre qui est ultra
compétente il me dit très très dur et
donc vu que le but d'une mule c'est de
presser un grain pour l'écraser c'est
normal de faire contre un truc dur
plutôt perdre que nous ce que j'en suis
fils assure du talc vu que c'est
complètement mousser le le talent que
roche à la base ça s'appelle de la
stéatite et ça c'est vraiment
complètement bon genre limite tu peux le
tordre et tout ça seulement et donc ça
pour une meule bas ça serait pas tant
que victime
à la stéatite facebook
la stéatite c'est bien le machin qu'on
appelle aussi pierre à savon ou quelques
coups ça doit être un truc dans le genre
étant à plusieurs couleurs sur ouais je
crois qu'il y en a un peu verte en
amérique centrale le genre de truc
mais ouais j'ai mis six statuettes chez
moi qu'il en amérique centrale en
stéatite et du coup il ya plein de
traces donc en dessous
a cette chance j'ai un peu point là oui
c'est hyper tendres j'ai principalement
tu peux l'oreiller tu peux faire des
traces comme dans du beurre korhogo
excellent hyper cool mais ça doit être
hyper pratique du coup pour faire des
oeuvres d'art moi j'imagine celle là
elle est en péril
ok
[Musique]